music is a major part of almost every
religious tradition whether it's
liturgical Music performed in the sake
of rituals the ecstatic performances of
Mystics hymns sung in church or the
recitation of Sacred Scriptures like The
Vedas or the Quran the Sonic or auditory
dimension of religious experience is a
significant one but one that is often
overlooked by scholars in favor of more
visual or perhaps text-based dimensions
and aspects we have already explored the
major role that music has played in the
religion of Islam through Sufism in a
previous episode and today we're going
to explore its sister religion of
Judaism in particular how have the
so-called Jewish Mystics employed and
imagined the role of Music throughout
history and today
[Applause]
Judaism is full of music there is music
in the synagogues music at wedding
celebrations music in the Hasidic
movement Etc to cover all of music and
Judaism would require a whole series so
we're going to limit ourselves here to
exploring music in the totally clear and
unproblematic concept of mysticism
that sarcasm by the way for the record
we are defining music in mysticism here
broadly as any music that is used or
makes up the content of Altered States
Of Consciousness or descriptions of
music as a significant part of a
metaphysical or cosmological framework
you may observe that that is also rather
broad which is true but we will try to
cover the topic as comprehensively as we
can so to begin with is there music in
Jewish mysticism there definitely is
both in what is known as Kabbalah which
could be considered a certain kind of
Jewish mysticism but also in Jewish
mysticism more broadly defined from the
oldest practices of the Israelite
prophets in ancient times through to the
ecstatic practices of Abraham abulafia
and the ecstatic kabbalist to the
theosophical speculation of the
capitalist in swats in the 16th century
all the way to the hasidot and the
otherwise known as the Hasidic movement
today there is a lot of stuff to store
here we can begin by rewinding the clock
to some of the most foundational periods
of judaism's development in the ancient
Israelite religion music seemed to have
played a major role indeed some of the
great Israelite prophets that are
mentioned in the Bible and the Quran
where musicians themselves King David
who is considered a prophet in Islam and
sometimes in certain strands of Judaism
and Christianity has being a musician as
one of his main characteristics being
referred to as an excellent player of
the liar or the loot indeed the Psalms a
major part of the Bible attributed to
David himself are essentially songs
often intended to have instrumental
accompaniment and there are other
figures too prophets who are reported to
have been musicians such as habakkuk but
aside from this prophecy and divine
revelation in ancient Jerusalem and the
Israelite religion seems to have been
intimately connected to music in and of
itself some of the prophets would have
used music as a way a technique of
reaching a state receptable to every
Revelation from God thus making it an
integral part of the prophetic
experience itself this can be seen in
biblical verses like in first Samuel
quote and there as soon as you come to
the city you will meet a group of
prophets coming down from the high place
with harp tambourine flute and liar
before them prophesying then the spirit
of the Lord will Rush upon you and you
will prophesy with them and be turned
into another man
or in Second Kings when the Prophet
Elijah attains prophetic experience
while hearing music quote but now bring
me a Minstrel or a musician and it came
to pass when the minister played that
the hand of the Lord came upon him these
two quotes in particular became very
popular to use for later Mystics in the
Middle Ages in support of their mystical
practices involving music as a means to
prophecy as we will see soon but it
certainly seems that there was a
connection between prophecy and music in
the earliest periods music had the
ability to affect the person to such a
degree that they could receive
Revelation from God not only this but
the sources also indicate that music
played a major role in the rituals in
the temple of Jerusalem the priest would
sing and sometimes play musical
instruments as they perform the
sacrifice and other rights the temple
practice also seemed to have involved
certain kinds of states that could be
deemed mystical with the help of musical
instruments and melodies the high priest
would enter a kind of mystical
experience the medieval capitalist Isaac
wrote quote the high priest knows how to
fully direct his concentration on all
inner and outer emanations in order to
exert influence by means of the secrets
of the Holy seraphim his elevation is
according to either his closeness or
remoteness his power is awakened by the
sweetness of the song and the pure
prayer so do the musicians direct their
fingers according to their elevation and
understanding placing them on the
keyholes of wind instruments kinorot and
on strings arousing the songs and the
melody to direct their hearts towards
God thus the blessing is aroused and the
Sharina resides in them on each one
according to his performance and
according to his understanding in other
words through the mystical experience
induced by music the shrina the divine
presence in the world sometimes
translated as the Holy Spirit sort of
descends and comes to reside in them now
this is a medieval Source talking about
ancient practices but other sources seem
to indicate similar things and it is
indeed in the Middle Ages that the world
of music and Jewish mysticism really
starts to pick up again because after
the destruction of the temple in
Jerusalem in the year 70 A.D there isn't
all that much in terms of references to
music being used uh in a you know
mystical sense in that way but from the
12th and 13th centuries when certain new
forms of Jewish mysticism really started
to develop and grow such as Kabbalah for
example we really start to see a new
flourishing and flowering of music as a
means to Mystical experience but also
music being used metaphorically in the
more metaphysical and cosmological
schemes of these kabbalists I should
point out that from now on I'm hugely
indebted to Moshe edel in particular who
has written a lot of articles on this
topic and a lot of what I present in
this episode will be based on a lot of
his writings the endlessly fascinating
figure of Abraham abulafia who founded
the form of Kabbalah referred to as
prophetic Kabbalah or ecstatic Kabbalah
developed intricate techniques of
reaching intense mystical experiences
the peak of which he considered to be
identical with prophecy these techniques
included the vocal recitation of vowels
or letters of the Hebrew alphabet
accompanied by certain movements and
other forms of meditation
and one important feature of this
practice was indeed music abulafa
himself writes quote make that special
breath as long as you can according to
your capacity for taking one long breath
as long as you can possibly make it and
sing the aleph in every other letter
which you Proclaim with all fear and
reverence until the joy of the soul is
combined with its understanding which is
great the form of the tune for each
letter should be in the image of the
vowel points it should be in the form of
the whole arm upwards end quote in
another text he says quote in this
matter he should transpose each letter
frontwards and backwards using many
tunes and of course these are obviously
very practical instructions and Deals
primarily with vocal music so using
Tunes or Melodies when pronouncing and
reciting these Divine names or letters
but we also see in some of abulafia's
students some of his later followers
that they also included certain musical
instruments in these kinds of practices
Judah Al botany writes quotes he should
continue to play on all sorts of musical
instruments if he has such or if he
knows how to play on them if not he
should make music with his mouth by
means of his voice singing the verses of
praise and out of love for the Torah in
order to Gladden the living Soul which
is partnered to the speaking
intellectual Soul end of quote so
clearly in the ecstatic Kabbalah of
abulafia and his followers music was an
important part of practice and could
lead to the highest forms of mystical
experience that of Prophecy
but what's going on here how do they
explain this apparent power of music
well Abu Lafia himself again says quote
the proof that song indicates the degree
of Prophecy is that it is the way of
song to make the heart Happy by means of
tunes as it is said and when the
minstrel played the power of the Lord
came upon him for prophecy does not
dwell in him unless there is Joy end of
quote the capitalists refer back to the
aforementioned Biblical verses as proof
that music can lead to prophecy and I
would love to hear explains that it
leads to a joy in the heart of the
person now when we talk about Abu Lafia
we need to understand that most of his
philosophical Outlook is based on the
writings of that greatest of Jewish
philosophers maimonides maimonides had
presented a philosophical theory of
Prophecy explaining the nature of
prophecy through the Aristotelian
philosophical language that he was
steeped in two maimonides it is the
intellect that is the star of the show
God is defined as pure intellect and it
is the intellectual part of human nature
that is the highest so to maimonides it
is through cultivating the intellect by
perfecting the human spirit that the
person received Revelation or prophecy
through a quote overflow overflowing
from God to the intellectual faculty in
other words prophecy is not some random
thing that just happens to a person
prophecy is instead earned so to say a
prophet is a person who is able to
perfect his nature his spirit and his
intellect so that it is perfectly
receptable to the Overflow from God this
is the way that the ancient prophets did
it and this is indeed the way that it
can be achieved today
this is what Abu Lasha and his followers
build on anyone can reach prophecy as
long as they practice in the right way
to purify the soul and the intellect
and just like the ancient prophets used
music to achieve this so do the
prophetic kabbalists music is very
effective in fact through its strong
impact on the soul furthermore going
back to abulafia Circle again one of his
followers wrote quote it was through the
enunciation of sound alone rising and
falling the main intention was to arouse
the soul to make use of all its glorious
power which is the power of intellectual
attainment and of course in other words
music has the ability to affect the soul
to arouse joy in the heart and to lead
the intellectual faculty to its highest
power ideally this would lead the
practitioner to experience
cleaving or uniting with the active
intellect of God or with God himself an
experience that is again identical to
prophecy The Scholar Moshe edel who is
one of the few who has written on this
topic extensively says quote music's
sphere of influence is the living Soul
its task is to make this Soul happy so
that it will not interfere with the
proper functioning of the intellectual
Soul or the intellect
some have argued that this use of Music
in contemplative and meditative
practices may have been influenced by
the sufis the so-called Islamic Mystics
who had a major presence in this region
at the time and there are certainly
similarities here to to consider but one
area in which the sufis were definitely
influential were in another movement of
Jewish mysticism in the 13th century
namely the pietistic movement led by
Abraham IBN maimon the son of maimonides
Abraham and the pietists developed forms
of prayer and meditation that seemed to
be heavily influenced by the sufis at
the time but which they themselves
claimed were ancient Israelite practices
that they were only Reviving music
played a major part in these practices
too which does make sense since it seems
that music was a major part of Prophecy
and the religious practices of the
ancient Israelites which Abraham and the
pietists were attempting to revive in
that way Abraham also followed his
father's theories and conceived of the
role of music and the prophetic
experience in a similar way to abulafia
prophecy could be attained through
spiritual purification and cultivation
of the intellect and music was a great
tool for that now sadly none of this
music survives today and there's really
no way for us to know what it sounded
like which in a way is a kind of tragedy
I think but it is really fascinating
stuff prophetic or ecstatic Kabbalah was
a significant movement which influenced
later developments but the most major
form of Kabbalah across history and that
which is most famous is what it's often
referred to as theosophical Kabbalah
which include all the theories
surrounding the tense we wrote and the
great book called The Zohar in early
theosophical Kabbalah we don't find as
many references to music used in a
practical sense but only in analogical
or metaphorical ways but especially if
we move a little ahead in history to the
time of the incredible kabbalistic
flowering in the city of SWAT or safed
around the 16th century there is a
little little more to grab a hold of
here great figures like Moshe cordovero
Joseph Caro and Isaac luria would
transform Kabbalah as we know it to the
theosophical capitalist music came to
have a theurgic power and use theurgic
meaning things humans do to affect the
Divine realm in Kabbalah as mentioned
there is often speculation around the
tense he wrote These can be seen as
Divine emanations also representing
God's attributes descending from the
infinite nature of God himself the ain't
soft and the highest sphera called
ketter all the way down to the last fira
and the created World below it there are
centuries of writings and speculation
around the nature of the sirot and there
is no way that we can cover it here but
one fascinating aspect of this general
theory has always been that there is a
kind of Correspondence between the
Divine world of the spherodes and our
world
things we do down here affect what
happens up there especially in the
writings of people like the
aforementioned Isaac luria we see the
idea that by following the mitzvot the
Jewish Commandments in the law we are in
a way completing or healing the spherot
US humans can influence and directly
affect the world of the Divine in some
way and the capitalist would use musical
language to explain this the
correspondence is described as the
resonance between two violins imagine
that you have two violins and you play
on a string on one of the violins this
will result in that same note or string
resonating in the other violin so this
is the way that the correspondence Works
what happens down here is mirrored up
there and vice versa and this is used to
explain the power of music too the
Spanish cabinet Rabbi mayod IBN gabai
wrote quote David said in order to
ensure that the glory that is the secret
of the Bride will sing out then chant to
thee I shall thank you forever
incessantly so that the glory on high
will also not be silent because just as
I am arousing here below so the arousal
will also be on high and the secret is
that the knesset of Israel that is
singing is the HARP of David and this is
the reason that it is incumbent to
arouse by means of a variety of Melodies
so as to draw down the Holy Spirit and
life from the source of life to his
attributes and this is the reason why
the first of the qualities was that he
had known to sing in other words because
our actions are mirrored in the Divine
realm just like the two violins or like
a shadow to its object when we play
music that music ascends to the world of
the spirit and is mirrored there
in a way thus us singing or playing
music makes God sing the music rising
from the lowest fira upwards throughout
the whole Tree of Life causing Harmony
between them and their own kind of music
this mirrored music which when
descending becomes identified with the
shrina the divine presence or the holy
spirit is that which comes over the
prophet or the person having a Divine
experience you could thus say that music
is the Earthly version or mirror of the
Holy Spirit itself which when played
causes the Divine to sing that song
being the Holy Spirit itself which
descends to our world it's profound
stuff
a similar idea is further developed by
one of the great figures of Kabbalah and
safed Moshe cordavero who writes quote
just as the supernal influx and the
Vitality descend from the world of
emanation and there it is pure but when
it descends to the world of creation and
from there to the world of formation it
becomes coarse so the sopranial song and
the arousal that ascends From Below
upward is purified and ascends from the
world of formation to that of creation
and from creation to emanation and
within the emanation from one degree to
another until it reaches the chambers
and addicts and there they will be
purified and ascends to cause Joy to the
Supreme Union between the spheroth of
hachma and BINA as usual with Kabbalah
this is filled with technical language
that is difficult to understand but
basically the song or music is in a way
identified with the Divine influx which
when ascending from our world to the
Divine World sort of affects the Divine
world of the spheroids and even
contributes to the union and Harmony
between these spherotes Moshe edel
explains quote the song is therefore no
different from the Divine influx it is a
mode of the Divine produced here below
when sent on high it becomes purified in
a manner reminiscent of the ascent of
the astral body in the ancient mystical
forms of literature in other words the
song is a spiritual energy a way to
respond to the Divine with a human
activity that affects the union between
the two hires he wrote there is a
relationship here where music can affect
the Divine realm which in itself of
course will affect the entire world and
this speaks to the power of music like
nothing else so while we don't find the
same prac practical use of Music in
these theosophical capitalists we can
still see how music is placed very
firmly and very profoundly within a
metaphysical and cosmological framework
and has given a very important role but
the circle in safarot's fat also came to
employ music in practical ways too
indeed the people around the great Isaac
luria essentially invented the Kabbalah
Shabbat ritual which take place every
Friday evening to welcome the Sabbath
and which involves songs that are
attributed to lyria himself and his
students the Kabbalah Shabbat is a
Mainstay in basically all Jewish weekly
rituals thus showing how much of an
impact the safadian group had on the
larger world of Judaism it also shows
that they obviously saw music as
important since they included
self-written songs as part of the
significant ritual all of these
developments came to influence the
Hasidic movement one of the most recent
manifestations of Jewish mysticism in
which music has come to play a very
major role here we see both the
theosophical speculations about about
music's influence on the Divine realm
developed by the kabbalist but the
khasidim has also always been heavily
focused on a personal inner
transformation and experience of the
Divine just like in abulafia the khasid
wants to achievecutes a union with the
Divine which is present everywhere at
all times and this means that the
khasidim also very much adapt the
perspectives on music held by the
prophetic capitalists associated with
abalafia music can not only outwardly
affect the world in the theoretical
sense but also transform the soul of the
individual and lead him to the
experience of God's imminence quotes if
words are the pen of the mind then music
is the quill of the Soul said Rabbi
shirazalman of liadi the founder of the
Chabad movement within hasidism indeed
it seems that from the very founding of
the Hasidic movement with the figure of
the balshem Tov music played a major
role he himself is said to have loved
music and made it a part of Hasidic
practice Rabbi nachman of brazlov one of
the balsham top students is attributed
with stating quote all melodies are
derived from the source of sanctity from
the Temple of Music impurity knows no
song because it knows no joy for it is
the source of all melancholy end of
quote and quote music originates from
the prophetic spirit and has the power
to elevate one to prophetic inspiration
end quote for this reason there
developed a very deep and varied
tradition of Hasidic music the most
famous of which is probably the negunim
Hasidic songs they're often vocal yet
wordless although some have also added
words to them instrumental as well as
vocal music make up the repertoire of
Hasidic music a genre that can vary a
lot from region to region and in these
circumstances it is used but regardless
the hasidim retained the mystical
connection and perspective on music as
not only fundamental in a metaphysical
way but also extremely powerful to help
the soul travel on the path to Union
with God perspectives which they
inherited from the great figures of
theosophical and prophetic Kabbalah so
while music and Judaism and Jewish
mysticism has obviously changed and
evolved over time and ideas and
perspectives have shifted there is a
line running through basically the whole
tradition
a line that starts with the ancient
prophets and their use of music as a
catalyst for Revelation and in the
temple of Jerusalem and which then runs
through the mystical employment and
theories surrounding it across history
all the way until today needless to say
music remains a significant part of
Judaism the Hasidic movement probably
Remains the most influential form of
Jewish mysticism today in which music
plays a major role as we have seen but
we've also seen a surge in popularity
for Kabbalah in the last few decades
which keeps alive the fascinating
speculations and theories of figures
like cordovaro Isaac lyria and Abraham
abulafia so next time you hear a really
good song try to remember how it
participates in the Eternal
correspondence between the Divine and
human realm and maybe interest you just
a little bit closer to spiritual
perfection
I'll see you next time
[Music]